So, listen, this is, I know Sean's favorite part of the show, the cold open. Yes, super fun. Chat and chew. Chat and chew. Well, but no, no, no, that is his really favorite part of the show is what follows here after the fun music he gets to do is coffee chat. But right now, he sort of welcomes the listener in. Right, yeah.
听着，我知道肖恩最喜欢节目的这个部分，即“冷开场”。是的，超级有趣。闲聊和八卦。闲聊和八卦。不过——不，不，不，他真正最喜欢的部分其实是接下来播放的好听音乐之后，他可以进行的咖啡闲聊。但现在，他算是对听众表示欢迎。对，没错。
How you doing? How's everybody going? And sort of gets a sense of everything, asks everybody how they're doing. And then like a little funny quip, like what's the bit going to be? Yeah, or I could do a dad joke, you know, or whatever. I could do like something like, I could do something like I asked him to do. Or, I know you could do that. Or you could just say to our audience, you could just say, hi.
“你们好吗？大家过得怎么样？”然后大致了解一下情况，问问每个人过得怎么样。接着来个搞笑的俏皮话，比如：今天的主题是什么？对啊，或者我可以讲个冷笑话，你知道的，诸如此类。我可以弄点像我让他做的那种东西。或者，我知道你可以那样做。或者你可以对我们的观众说，你可以简单说声：嗨。
Hi. Welcome to Smartless. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
嗨。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. I have to say something. Okay, this year, you guys, both of two of my best friends in the whole world, you, both of you, are doing some of the best work I've ever seen you do. I'm hanging out with Will on the set of his movie, and I've seen some footage, and Will, the work is truly, truly incredible. This is what I'm hearing, Will.
Less。我得说点什么。好吧，今年，你们两个——我全世界最好的两个朋友，你们两个，正在做我见过的最棒的工作。我和威尔在他的电影片场，我看到了一些素材，威尔，那真是——真是令人难以置信。这就是我听到的，威尔。
Truly incredible, mind-blowing. I've never seen, people are gonna be blown away. Not surprised. And Jay, when I sat down and watched Black Rabbit, I've already spoken about it, this year is so exciting, I'm so excited for people to see both of you in these two incredible pieces,
真是令人难以置信，太震撼了。我从未见过，人们会被惊艳到的。毫不意外。而杰伊，当我坐下来看《黑兔》（Black Rabbit）时，我已经谈过这个了，今年真是太令人兴奋了，我太激动了，迫不及待想让大家看到你们俩在两部极其出色的作品中的表现——
and I know you cringe when I say this, pieces of art, because I do believe that they're two pieces of art. Well thank you coming from the reigning Tony Award winning. Yeah, yeah, yeah, well that's not why I said it. It's not why I said it. No, but you set the tone for us. You kind of let out, and you know, what a performance!
我知道当我这么说时你会觉得不好意思，艺术品，因为我的确相信那是两件艺术品。好吧，谢谢你，这话出自新晋托尼奖得主之口。对，对，对，好吧，我可不是为了这个才这么说的。我才不是为了这事说的。不，不过你为我们定下了基调。你算是把情绪释放出来了，你知道，多么精彩的表演！
Really spicy from the Tabasco, dear sir! And now, and now. That was unexpected. Nobody thought. Watch him go back. That's as he's getting yanked out. Nobody. I have a good, wait, I have a good.
塔巴斯哥辣酱可真够味儿，尊敬的先生！而现在，而现在。真是出人意料。谁也没想到。看他被拉回去。就在他被拽出去的时候。没有谁。我有个好主意，等等，我有个好。
When do we start recording this episode, you guys? I got a heart out. I know. Wait, listen, wait. Sean, your guess is going crazy. Do you want me, I know, I'm a good- When do we start recording this episode, you guys? I got a hard out. No, I know. Right, listen, wait. Sean, your guess is going crazy right now. Do you want me, I know I'm gonna get there, but do you want me to ask you guys a thoughtful question that we can riff on,
我们什么时候开始录制这一集啊，各位？我一会儿有急事得走。我知道。等等，听着，等等。肖恩，你的嘉宾快疯了。你想让我——我知道，我很棒——我们什么时候开始录制这一集啊，各位？我有一个硬性离开时间。不，我知道。对，听着，等等。肖恩，你的嘉宾现在快疯了。你想让我——我知道我会说到那儿的，但你是想让我问你们一个有深度的问题，我们可以就此即兴发挥，
or I can have a joke, or we can just get to the guess? Choice of pattern today, huh? Yeah. What do you want? What's happening? You've had some time? We haven't done one of these in a couple of weeks. I guess you've got some material.
还是我来讲个笑话，或者我们直接切入正题采访嘉宾？今天这是什么套路啊，哈？没错。你们想怎么样？怎么回事？你有一段时间没出场了？我们已经好几周没录过这种了。我猜你准备了一些段子。
That's what I'm saying, that's what I'm saying. I'd love a dad joke. I'd like a dad joke. Okay, well this is the, I have, okay, I can do a dad joke, I can also do a, this is a great joke I just heard yesterday. Fuck, you have genres of jokes too? Like you have subsections to you.
这就是我想说的，这就是我想说的。我想要个冷笑话。我想要个冷笑话。好吧，这个是，我有，好吧，我可以讲个冷笑话，我还可以讲个——这是我昨天刚听到的一个极好的笑话。操，你连笑话都有不同类型？就像你身上还有各种子分类一样。
All right, so this guy, this patient is in your, that patient is in a urologist office and the doctor says, well, the result is that you gotta stop masturbating. And the patient says, why? And the doctor says, because I'm talking to you. I love it. Oh, really?
好吧，所以这个家伙，这个病人在你——那个病人在泌尿科医生的诊所里，医生说：“嗯，结果就是你得停止手淫。”然后病人问：“为什么？”医生说：“因为我在跟你说话。”我太喜欢了。哦，真的吗？
I thought that was funny. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. Oh, wait, and then I got, wait, do I have? I've got one like that, but I don't have it yet. You know what?
我觉得这挺好笑的。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。哦，等等，然后我还有，等等，我有吗？我有一个类似这样的，但我现在想不起来了。你知道吗？
It's all rusted. How about this? Yeah, go ahead. Why did the Mexican take anti-anxiety medication? Hmm, careful. For Hispanic attacks? Oh, that's all right, that's okay. I feel like that's okay. I feel like that's okay. All right, great.
全生锈了。这个怎么样？行，说吧。为什么那个墨西哥人要吃抗焦虑药？嗯，小心点。为了“西斯 panic”发作？（译者注：此处涉及英文谐音梗，Hispanic 发作谐音为 His-panic / Panic attack）哦，没关系，这可以。我觉得这可以。我觉得这可以。好吧，太棒了。
Yeah, all right, let's get to the end. But also, for the record, no reaction. That was a zero reaction, story of my life. Ready, here we go. I'm your America Gafan now. Guys, my guest today, who's far funnier than I am, grew up in the Kansas City area, and he's a diehard-
行，好吧，我们进入正题吧。但话说回来，全场零反应。一点反应也没有，我的人生写照。准备好了，我们开始。我现在是你的美国加凡（Gafan）了。伙计们，我今天的嘉宾，比我幽默得多，他在堪萨斯城地区长大，是个死忠的——
Jason Sudeikis. Diehard Kansas City Chiefs fan. He's the co-owner of a candy store in Rhinebeck, New York. Paul Rudd. Paul Rudd. Paul Rudd, let's just bring him out. And he once said his secret for staying youthful and fit as eight hours of sleep. This should just bring him out. This is Paul Rudd.
杰森·苏戴奇斯（Jason Sudeikis）。堪萨斯城酋长队的死忠球迷。他是纽约州莱茵贝克一家糖果店的联合老板。保罗·路德。保罗·路德。保罗·路德，我们把他请出来吧。他曾说过保持年轻和健康的秘诀是睡八个小时。这下该把他请出来了。这就是保罗·路德。
This should just bring him out. You gotta bury the tell stuff. You gotta bury the tell stuff. People often still mistake him for Ben Affleck. He met his wife when looking for a publicist after filming Clueless. It's the hilarious, delightful, and widely talented Paul Rudd.
这下该把他请出来了。你得把爆料藏在后面。你得把爆料藏在后面。人们现在还经常把他误认成本·阿弗莱克。他在拍完《独领风骚》（Clueless）后寻找公关时遇到了他的妻子。他就是搞笑、迷人且才华横溢的保罗·路德。
What? Paul? Wait, did you guys already? A slight reveal. Let's see it just in his mouth. Oh, he's doing his, he's just doing a slight reveal. This is long overdue. How did you know he was from Kansas City?
什么？保罗？等等，你们刚才已经？一个小小的亮相。看他只是动了动嘴。哦，他在搞他的，他只是做了一个小小的亮相。这真是久违了。你怎么知道他是堪萨斯城人？
Guys. Because there's only a few. There's Claire McCaskill, there's Rob Riggle, there's Jason Sondickis, and there's all that. How do you know that? Paul, do you get mistaken for Claire McCaskill a lot? I get a lot of her emails. Okay, okay.
伙计们。因为那里没几个人。有克莱尔·麦卡斯基尔（Claire McCaskill），有罗卜·里格尔（Rob Riggle），有杰森·苏戴奇斯，还有诸如此类的人。你怎么知道这个的？保罗，你经常被误认成克莱尔·麦卡斯基尔吗？我经常收到她的电子邮件。好吧，好吧。
And it's usually when they talk about the three from KC. The big three. It's Sudeikis, me and McCaskill. How has it taken this long for Sean? I feel like this is Sean's fault. Couldn't make your deal any earlier than now. And now finally you've given us a manageable price. Aline Kashishian was rough in the negotiation.
而且通常是在他们谈论来自堪萨斯城的三个大人物时。三巨头。就是苏戴奇斯、我和麦卡斯基尔。肖恩怎么花了这么长时间才把请来？我觉得这是肖恩的错。你的出场费直到现在才谈拢。现在你终于给我们开出了一个可以接受的价格。阿琳·卡什希安（Aline Kashishian）在谈判时可真难缠。
Was she tough? She was like, oh, are you with Aline too, Paul? Yeah, yeah, there's a package right on this. That's your manager, that's great. Always. She's great. Back when she was, she was my agent when she was an assistant. That's how far back we go.
她很强硬吗？她当时说：“哦，保罗，你也是阿琳手下的艺人吗？”对，对，这上面直接就是一个打包套餐。那是你的经纪人，这太棒了。一直都是。她太棒了。当她还是个助理的时候，她就是我的经纪人了。我们认识那么久了。
No way. Oh wow, how about that? Wait a second, so she was working the phones for the real agent and that real agent kind of siphoned you off on the junior slash receptionist. ICM. It was right around, since kind of clueless. Yeah. Wow.
不会吧。哦，哇，原来是这样？等一下，所以她当时是在为真正的经纪人接电话，而那个真正的经纪人把你转给这个初级兼职接待员了？ICM公司。那正好是，差不多是在《独领风骚》那个时期。对。哇。
Wow. And wait, I want to go back, because I didn't know you own a candy store. Can you talk to me about the candy store, please? Sure. Like, where is it? Oh, you had an address on it? Sure.
哇。等等，我想回到刚才的话题，因为我不知道你还经营着一家糖果店。能跟我讲讲这家糖果店的事吗？当然。比如，它在哪儿？哦，你刚才有它的地址？当然。
I want to cover Sean's passion. Well, it's called Samuel's Sweet Shop, and it's in Rhinebeck, New York. Wow. And it was started by a guy named Ira. Sure. And he was just this sweet guy, and he passed away sadly, when he was very young.
我想聊聊肖恩的挚爱。嗯，它叫塞缪尔糖果店（Samuel's Sweet Shop），位于纽约州莱茵贝克。哇。它是由一个叫艾拉（Ira）的家伙创立的。没错。他是个非常甜美的人，但不幸的是他在很年轻的时候就去世了。
And we didn't want the candy store to kind of go away, and he passed away sadly when he was very young. And we didn't want the candy store to kind of go away because it's not a big place, it's not a big town and all the high school kids would work there and everyone needs a candy store. And so Jeffrey Dean Morgan and Hillary Burton who are neighbors of mine. Yeah, let's, yeah.
我们不想让这家糖果店就这么消失了，他不幸去世时还很年轻。我们不想让这家糖果店就这么消失，因为这不是个大地方，也不是个大镇子，所有的高中生都在那里打工，每个人都需要一家糖果店。所以杰弗里·迪恩·摩根（Jeffrey Dean Morgan）和希拉里·伯顿（Hillary Burton），他们是我的邻居。对，让我们，对。
I know me some Jeffrey Dean. You do? I like all his performances. Sorry. Anyway, we went in and another guy named Andy Ostroy, we went in and bought the candy store and now we run it. Now, Rheinbeck is... You can't walk there from the city, right?
我跟杰弗里·迪恩挺熟的。是吗？我喜欢他所有的表演。抱歉。不管怎样，我们和另一个叫安迪·奥斯特罗伊（Andy Ostroy）的家伙一起去买下了这家糖果店，现在我们自己在经营它。莱茵贝克是……从城里没法步行过去吧，对吧？
That's a trip. You can, it'll take you a while. Yeah. You'd need a lot of candy to fuel it. Yeah. Is it, it's like a two hour drive? It's about a two hour drive. Yeah, about an hour, depending on if you're leaving from the Upper West Side,
那可是一段行程。可以走，就是得花点时间。对。你需要吃很多糖果来补充体力。对。那是，大概要开车两小时？大约两小时车程。对，大约一个小时，这取决于你是不是从上西区出发，
it's about an hour and 45. Well, I'll get a head start. Jenny Slate also owns a small store like Upstate New York. Massachusetts. Oh, nevermind, moving on. A general storage. She has a general storage. Same with that.
大约一个小时四十五分钟。那我得提前出发了。珍妮·斯蕾特（Jenny Slate）在纽约州北部也拥有一家小店。马萨诸塞州。哦，没关系，我们继续。一家杂货店。她有一家杂货店。差不多也是那样。
Correll, too. Are we going to start going down, Sean, you want to start listing people who also own businesses? Just come on down to 85 and let us know. Paul's got a candy store in Rhineback, okay, started by Ira. And that's it. Wait, so go back, so you met Aline that way,
卡瑞尔（Carell）也是。我们是不是要开始往下数了，肖恩，你想开始列举那些也拥有自己业务的人吗？直接拨打85号热线告诉我们吧。保罗在莱茵贝克开了一家糖果店，好吧，由艾拉创立的。就这样。等等，我们回过头去，所以你是通过这种方式认识阿琳的，
and then you met your wife because you were looking for a publicist, is that right? Yes, well, I was the director of Clueless. You were the director? Amy Heckerling. So Amy Heckerling said, after we filmed Clueless, I knew nothing about anything, I still don't that much, really, but.
然后你遇到了你的妻子，因为你在找一个公关，是这样吗？是的，嗯，我是《独领风骚》的导演。你是导演？艾米·海克林（Amy Heckerling）。所以艾米·海克林说，在我们拍完《独领风骚》之后，我对任何事情都一无所知，现在其实也了解得不多，不过——
Were you Clueless? I was Clueless, well done. You. Welcome to Smartless. Guys, we're cooking with gas. Emphasis on smart. I mean. By the way, I love Julie, your wife Julie. She's awesome.
你当时“克鲁斯”了吗（一语双关，Clueless意为无知/懵懂，也是电影名）？我当时“克鲁斯”了，干得漂亮。你。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。伙计们，我们正干得热火朝天。重点在“Smart（聪明）”。我是说。
Oh, thank you. And she loves me. Julie, that's what it is. Thank you. She loves you guys. And she said to say hi, and she also said say nice things about her. So I love my wife. And she's an say hi and she also said say nice things about her. So I love my wife and she's an avid listener.
顺便说一句，我非常喜欢朱莉，你的妻子朱莉。她太棒了。哦，谢谢。她也很喜欢我。朱莉，就是这样。谢谢。她很喜欢你们。她让我代她向你们问好，她还说要多说点她的好话。所以我爱我的妻子。她是个代她向你们问好，她还说要多说点她的好话。所以我爱我的妻子，而且她是个狂热的听众。
And then we just hear the page flip and then you. And now it's enough of her. And so yeah, so what were you talking about? I was talking about meeting Julie, looking for a publicist on Clueless, Amy Heckerling. Paul, you're upstate, so you meet your wife Julie, you meet her through, she's your publicist, we've been through that.
然后我们听到翻书声，接着就是你。好了，关于她的就够了。所以，是的，刚才你们在聊什么？我当时在聊遇到朱莉的事，在《独领风骚》时找公关，艾米·海克林。保罗，你住在纽约州北部，所以你遇到了你的妻子朱莉，你是通过她认识的，她是你的公关，我们已经谈过这个了。
I mean, let's just get down to that. Here are the brass tacks. Nobody really cares. You are a guy who has been- They do, I do. You've been working at the highest level for over 30 years, and I mean that in a way. You have been consistently doing stuff, comedy, drama,
我的意思是，我们直奔主题吧。这就是核心事实。其实没人真正在乎。你是一个——他们才在乎，我在乎。你从事最高水平的工作已经超过30年了，我是说真的。你一直在源源不断地做各种事情，喜剧、戏剧，
all this, like, right? Always at the- No missteps. No missteps. Yeah, not one. I think there no missteps. Yeah, not one. I think there are a few. No, not even, not even Halloween, no, Halloween six, not even that. I saw that, you were fucking great in that.
所有这些，对吧？一直都在——没有失误。没有失误。是的，一个都没有。我觉得没有什么失误。对，一个都没有。我觉得有那么几个。不，连……连《月光光心慌慌6》（Halloween 6）都没有，甚至连那部也没有。我看过那部，你在里面棒极了。
That was 75 years ago. That was so good. That's the first thing I ever did, the first movie. No, was it really? Is that true? Yeah, did, now, had you seen the first five parts? Are you kidding me? Were you lost in the storyline?
那是75年前的事了。那部太棒了。那是我拍的第一部作品，第一部电影。不，真的吗？真的吗？是的，话说回来，你看过前五部吗？你在开玩笑吧？你在剧情里迷失了吗？
I've seen all of them. I saw all of them. You saw them all? Yeah, I loved them. I saw the first and parts where you lost in the storyline. I've seen all of them. I saw all of them. You saw them all. Yeah, I saw the first and loved it. There was five more. Is that right? No, he was in six. There might even be more than that, yeah.
我都看过。我都看过。你全看过？对，我都喜欢。我看过第一部，你在剧情里迷失了吗？我都看过。我都看过。你全看过。对，我看过第一部并且很喜欢。后面还有五部呢。是吗？不，他演的是第六部。甚至可能还有更多，对吧？
The first is a classic. When you get to six, plot holes. What are you talking about? I loved it. There's some shark jumping? Yeah. Oh yeah. Do you end up getting killed in that one, spoiler?
第一部是经典。当你看到第六部时，剧情漏洞就出来了。你在说什么呢？我挺喜欢的。有些情节开始强行编造了吗？（译者注：Jump the shark，指影视剧质量下滑的转折点）哦，对。你最后在里面被干掉了吗，剧透一下？
No, I survived. Do you end up getting killed in that one, spoiler? No, I survived. Do you get a good shot in on him? I remember, yeah, we get into it. We had some scrapes. A knife fight? Yeah, now because you've done so many movies, do you really truly remember? Sorry, what Jason's asking.
不，我活下来了。你最后在里面被干掉了吗，剧透一下？不，我活下来了。你给过他狠狠的一击吗？我记得，对，我们打起来了。有一场刀战？对，既然你拍过那么多电影，你真的还记得吗？抱歉，杰森在问什么。
Wait, I wanna wrap, what was the weapon that you guys were tossing with you and Mike Myers? I think I hit him with a pipe. Okay. I think I maybe hit him with a pipe. That's a good choice. So you stun him for a second, but then he continues after you. Yeah, by the way, didn't kill him.
等等，我想总结一下，你和迈克尔·迈尔斯（Mike Myers）手里拿的是什么武器扔来扔去？我想我用一根水管砸了他。好吧。我想我可能用一根水管砸了他。这是个好选择。所以你把他打懵了一会儿，但接着他又追过来了。对，顺便说一句，没杀死他。
He never runs. It didn't kill him. No, that's what's horrifying about Mike Myers, is that he never runs, he just walks, because he's going to get you. He just walks. He's going to take his time. Did you ever do a tie-in around Halloween
他从来都不跑。没杀死他。不，迈克尔·迈尔斯最可怕的地方就在于他从来不跑，他只是走着，因为他一定要抓到你。他只是走着。他有的是时间。你有没有在万圣节期间
at the candy store with like photos of yourself from the Steels 3 movie? That'd be good. That's a great idea. Thank you, Will. That's a great idea. I haven't done it. Yeah.
在糖果店里搞过什么联动，比如摆上你在《月光光心慌慌3》里的剧照？那倒挺不错的。这主意真棒。谢谢你，威尔。这主意真棒。我还没这么做过。对。
I haven't really done that yet, but maybe this year. Write this stuff down, Paul. So you end up surviving six, but was not in seven. Did you? No. I didn't, they didn't ask me about seven.
我其实还没这么干过，不过也许今年可以。把这些记下来，保罗。所以你最后在第六部里活下来了，但第七部里没有你。是吗？没有。我没有，他们没有找我演第七部。
They did like a cast change like Fargo or. I think they kind of went. I want to say in seven it might have been Josh Hartnett. They did a white lotus swap. That might have been H2O. Oh, H2O, I remember that one. I think it came back strong in seven. If I had been a reviewer of seven
他们换了一批演员，就像《冰血暴》（Fargo）那样。我想他们在第七部里可能换成了乔什·哈奈特（Josh Hartnett）。他们来了个《白莲花度假村》式的换角。那可能是《H2O抓鬼节》（H2O）。哦，《H2O》，我记得那部。我觉得第七部卷土重来，表现很强劲。如果我是第七部的影评人，
and that you weren't in it, my headline for my review would have been all trick and no treat. Oh, geez. You know? Oh, man. You know, Paul, you're in a pretty special episode of Smarts Reel so far.
而你又没有参演，我那篇影评的标题就会是：全是噱头，没有实质。（译者注：All trick and no treat，化用万圣节习俗 trick or treat）哦，天哪。你知道吗？哦，天哪。你知道吗，保罗，到目前为止，你在《Smartless》里经历了一次相当特殊的客串。
We're only 31 minutes in. That's really sweet. And we're not even to the first question yet. 29 of which my microphone went down. I know. I did want to know. Can I just say also how fun it is, just to listen to you guys. Well, keep your knees bent, we're only halfway through.
我们才播了31分钟。这真暖心。而且我们甚至还没进入第一个问题呢。其中有29分钟我的麦克风都是坏的。我知道。我其实挺想知道的——我能顺便说一句，光是听你们聊天有多开心吗？好吧，把膝盖弯好，我们才进行到一半。
To listen to you guys before I come on and to hear the jokes, which I really, really liked. Did you like my urologist joke? I did like the urologist, you're the one. Yeah. I'm a fan of the dad jokes. I heard one not that long ago that I really liked, which was,
在我上场之前听你们聊天，听那些笑话，我是真的很喜欢。你喜欢我的泌尿科医生笑话吗？我确实喜欢那个泌尿科医生的笑话，你最会讲了。对。我是冷笑话的粉丝。不久前我听到一个我很喜欢的笑话，就是，
where do the McKid melons go for the summer? Where? Where? John Cougar's melon camp. Nice, that's a good one. I love it. I've remembered my urologist joke. Guy goes in for a prostate exam.
小甜瓜们夏天都去哪儿？哪儿？哪儿？约翰·库格·坎普的甜瓜夏令营。（译者注：John Cougar Mellencamp是个美国摇滚歌手，Mellencamp谐音Melon-camp甜瓜营）太棒了，这个好。我喜欢。我想起我的泌尿科医生笑话了。有个家伙去做前列腺检查。
Shit, oh my God. No, Jesus. No, this is bad. Come on, watch this, Paul, watch this. We don't have any kids listening to this. Like a good prostate just joke. Guy goes in for a prostate exam. Shit, oh my God. No, Jesus, no. Come on, watch this, Paul, watch this. We don't have any kids listening to this. Like a good prostate exam joke. No, Paul, watch how you bludgeon a joke. Keep going, Jason. Watch, go, Jason, try it.
操，哦天哪。不，耶稣。不，这太糟糕了。拜托，看这个，保罗，看这个。我们这可没有小孩子在听。就像一个好的前列腺检查笑话。有个家伙去做前列腺检查。操，哦天哪。不，耶稣，不。拜托，看这个，保罗，看这个。我们这可没有小孩子在听。就像一个好的前列腺检查笑话。不，保罗，看你是怎么把一个笑话砸手里的。继续讲，杰森。看，上，杰森，你来试试。
I will stumble right before I cross, right before I chest the tape, I will fall. Here we go. So Guy walks in, you're all just, hey, he's gotta get his prostate exam, and so he's gotta lean over the table, he's gotta get his prostate exam. And so he's gotta lean over the table, he's gotta get the old, whew, and so the doctor says, okay-doke, here we go.
我会在冲刺前绊倒，就在快要撞线的一刹那，我会摔倒。我们开始。所以有个家伙走进去，泌尿科医生，嘿，他得做前列腺检查，所以他得俯身趴在桌上，他得做前列腺检查。所以他得俯身趴在桌上，接受那个老套餐，呼，于是医生说：“好了啦，我们开始。”
This time, Jimmy, no hard on. And the guy turns around and says, my name's Bill. He goes, yeah, no, I'm Jimmy. Yeah. That's not even. I've heard Jason try to tell that joke 50 times. By the way, it's a great joke. One time he's like, and the guy, Paul says, and then Paul says, Jimmy, and he goes, I've heard Jason try to tell that joke 50 times. One time he's like, and the guy Paul says, and then Paul says, Jimmy, and he goes, Bill,
“这次，吉米，别起生理反应。”然后那家伙转过身来说：“我叫比尔。”医生说：“哦，对，我是吉米。”对。这甚至都不是。我已经听杰森讲过这个笑话50遍了。有一次他讲得像——保罗说，然后保罗说：“吉米”，然后他说——我已经听杰森讲过这个笑话50遍了。有一次他讲得像——保罗说，然后保罗说：“吉米”，然后他说：“比尔，
I'm not Paul, I'm Jim. And I'm like, what are you, and I looked at him, like, what are you doing? Listen, I don't write. I speak. Wait, we're going to get to your life. Okay, here's Sean. Sean, I'm going to grab the reins here. So Paul.
我不是保罗，我是吉姆。”然后我就想，你在干吗，我看着他，就像，你在干吗？听着，我不负责写。我负责说。等等，我们要聊聊你的生活了。好吧，肖恩来了。肖恩，我要把谈话的主动权抓过来了。所以，保罗。
What are you talking about? I've been trying. No, because you've been, you're all gussied up on Pop Tarts. Paul. Yeah. So, I was saying that you've been at the top of the level. So, you start out of the gate. Sure, you do Halloween six.
你在说什么呢？我一直在努力。不，因为你一直在——你吃着波特面包卷正得意呢。保罗。对。所以，我刚才说你一直处于行业顶端。所以，你一出道——当然，你拍了《月光光心慌慌6》。
It's amazing. But then you do like, you just do so many movies. So, how was it that you came, what was the thing, first of all, what was your first professional job? Not necessarily movie, but how did you know, like it seems like you've been doing it at the highest level from moment one.
太惊艳了。但随后你拍了——你拍了那么多电影。所以，你是怎么走到这一步的？首先，你的第一份职业是什么？不一定是电影，但你是怎么知道的——看起来你从一开始就处于最高水平。
But what was moment one for you? Like how did you leave Kansas City? What was that thing? Did you move to New York? Oh yeah, I didn't have any of those questions prepared. Go ahead, Paul. Well, fuck, we're 25 minutes in, man. What was Paul's fault is that?
但对你来说，最初的起点是什么？比如你是怎么离开堪萨斯城的？那是怎么回事？你搬到纽约了吗？哦，对，我根本没准备这些问题。你接着说，保罗。好吧，操，我们已经聊了25分钟了，老兄。那是保罗的错吗？
Well. Paul's microphone. It is, totally. it's this weak connection that I have. Thank you for saying that, Will. It's not, it's a. Thank you, Carl. I don't think it's totally true. I've made many missteps and I've been very fortunate in many instances, but when I was a kid,
好吧。保罗的麦克风。是的，完全是。因为我这里的连接太弱了。谢谢你这么说，威尔。这不是——这是一个。谢谢你，卡尔。我觉得这不完全对。我犯过很多失误，在很多情况下我也非常幸运，但当我还是个孩子的时候，
I just loved comedians. I loved watching SNL and all of that stuff and listening to Steve Martin albums. And I think that when I was kind of in school, we had speech class, we had a radio and TV class. I loved watching the David Letterman show and I used to start making little videos like he used to do.
我就是疯狂热爱喜剧。我喜欢看《周六夜后》（SNL）所有那些节目，喜欢听史蒂夫·马丁（Steve Martin）的专辑。我觉得当我在上学的时候，我们有演讲课，有广播电视课。我喜欢看大卫·莱特曼（David Letterman）的节目，我开始模仿他的做法制作一些小视频。
And I used to perform in speech competitions. And when I was, I want to say about 16 years old, my neighbor in Kansas City said, what do you think you want to study? What do you think you want to pursue? And I said, I don't know, I like the arts and I like drawing and all of that. And he said, what about an actor?
我经常参加演讲比赛。当我有——我想大概16岁的时候，我在堪萨斯城的邻居问我：“你觉得你想学什么？你想追求什么职业？”我说：“我不知道，我喜欢艺术，我喜欢画画之类的一切。”他说：“当个演员怎么样？”
It seems like that's something that you would maybe like to do. And I think it was some kind of lightning bolt moment where I thought, yeah, maybe that is what I'd like to do. Because I certainly always liked funny stuff and movies and everything else. And it feels like from that moment on, I decided, oh, this is exactly what I'm gonna try and pursue.
“感觉这可能是你或许会喜欢做的事。”我想那就像是一个闪电击中的时刻，我心想：“对啊，也许这正是我想要去做的。”因为我确实一直都喜欢搞笑的东西、电影以及其他所有一切。感觉就是从那一刻起，我决定：“哦，这正是我要尝试去追求的目标。”
And I then went to school for it and I studied it. And what was this humorous interpretation thing? Because we had something similar in high school, but it was called forensics. I don't know why it was called forensics. Yeah, forensics, exactly. It was called forensics in Kansas City too. And sometimes I would tell people I study forensics
然后我去上学并为此进行了学习。那个“幽默演绎”的项目是怎么回事？因为我们在高中也有类似的东西，但叫“法证学”（forensics）。我不知道为什么它叫法证学。对，法证学，没错。在堪萨斯城它也叫法证学。有时我会告诉别人我学的是法证学，
and they think it's like what Quincy did. Yeah, right. Quincy, yeah, Quincy. For all the young listeners, Quincy. Do we know why it's called forensics, Sean? I don't, I don't. And in high school, people would be standing against a wall and talking to it, like,
他们会以为那是昆西（Quincy）干的那种事。（译者注：Quincy指美国老牌侦探悬疑剧《Quincy, M.E.》）对，没错，昆西，昆西。致所有年轻的听众，昆西。我们知道它为什么叫法证学吗，肖恩？我不知道，我不知道。在高中里，人们会靠着墙自言自语，就像，
and I didn't know what they were doing, but they were rehearsing, like, but really close to a wall and talking to a wall, I thought that was the weirdest thing. But now I get it, they were just rehearsing their monologue or their forensics or whatever it was. You sure you weren't institutionalized, you weren't in an institution at that point? the weirdest thing, but now I get it, they were just rehearsing their monologue or their forensics or whatever it was. You sure you weren't institutionalized,
我当时不知道他们在干什么，但他们其实是在排练，而且离墙贴得特别近对着墙说话，我觉得这简直是世界上最诡异的事。但现在我懂了，他们当时只是在排练他们的独白、法证学朗诵或者诸如此类的东西。你确定你当时不是被送进精神病院了吗？你当时没在精神病院里吧？
you weren't in an institution at that point? Is there a chance? It looks like an institution. You may have still been at the hospital, Sean. Yeah. It wasn't even comedic forensics? That I didn't understand. Well, there were different categories.
有这种可能吗？看起来就像个精神病院。你可能当时还在医院里呢，肖恩。对。甚至都不是喜剧类的法证学吗？那个我就不懂了。好吧，当时有很多不同的类别。
There was dramatic interpretation, humorous interpretation, prose and poetry, improvised duet acting. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So Paul, I heard you were a DJ for a while, right? Well, I mean, barely. You know, I did. Oh, okay, I thought it was like a long, I thought it was a mean, barely. You know, I did.
有戏剧演绎、幽默演绎、散文与诗歌、即兴双人表演。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以保罗，我听说你曾经当过一段时间DJ，对吧？嗯，我是说，勉强算吧。你知道的，我干过。哦，好吧，我还以为那是——我以为那是——我是说，勉强算吧。你知道的，我干过。
Oh, okay, I thought it was like a long, I thought it was a year's long thing. I really did DJ, but when you say to people that, oh, I used to DJ, that sounds like it was kind of a cool thing, but the way I DJed was not cool in any way. It was like weddings and bar mitzvahs and stuff? Yeah, bar mitzvahs. And by the way, eventually it was that.
哦，好吧，我还以为那是持续了很久的事，我真的当过DJ，但当你对别人说“哦，我以前当过DJ”时，听起来好像是一件挺酷的事，但我当年当DJ的方式一点也不酷。就像婚礼、犹太成人礼（Bar Mitzvah）那种的？对，犹太成人礼。而且顺便说一句，最后确实是那样。
The first time I DJed was, I was in high school. It's just an ice cream truck. And I went, nobody, they're like, we don't even have equipment in this thing. I was trying to get a job as a waiter. I was in high school. And I went to different restaurants and I had really long hair. And I didn to different restaurants
我第一次当DJ的时候，我还在上学。那只是一辆冰淇淋车。然后我去——没人，他们说：“我们这车里连设备都没有。”我当时正想找份服务员的工作。我还在上学。我去了不同的餐厅，我留着一头长发。我当时——我去了不同的餐厅，
and I had really long hair and I didn't want to cut my hair because I was a cheeseball. And I'm like, I gotta keep this. You're crushing it. And so I was getting rejected at every waiting application fill out. Like there's no way, I couldn't get a job. And I went to this bar called Studebakers, which was like a 50s bar in Kansas City.
我留着一头长发，而且我不想剪头发，因为我就是个老土。我想：“我必须保留这个。”你简直酷毙了。所以我填写的每一份服务员工作申请都被拒绝了。根本没戏，我找不到工作。我去了这家叫斯图贝克（Studebakers）的酒吧，那是堪萨斯城的一家50年代风格的酒吧。
Had to be 23 to get in. They didn't want any of the younger crowd. Wow. Sure. Yeah. They didn't even want new drinkers. You had to have at least two years under your belt. They want some certified 23 yearyear-olds who like, who's gonna go to a 50s bar anyway?
必须满23岁才能进。他们根本不想要任何年轻面孔。哇。确实。他们甚至不想要刚开始喝酒的顾客。你至少得有两年的饮酒资历才行。他们想要那些经过认证的、喜欢去50年代酒吧的23岁年轻人？
Yeah. Right. You had to be born in the 50s to get here. To even wanna go to this place. That's funny. And so I went to try and get a job and they said, we're not hiring. And I saw that they had a DJ booth. And I said, do you need a DJ? Because I also say, we're not hiring. And I saw that they had a DJ booth and I said,
对。没错。你得是50年代出生的才能来这儿。甚至才想来这个地方。太搞笑了。所以我去那儿应聘工作，他们说：“我们不招人。”然后我看到他们有一个DJ台，我就说：“你们需要DJ吗？”因为我也——他们说：“我们不招人。”然后我看到他们有一个DJ台，我就说：
do you need a DJ? Because I also DJ, which is not true, I didn't. But they said, actually we do. But here's the thing, at Studebakers, every hour on the hour we do these things called Showtimes where all the waiters hop on the bar and they do like, born to hand jive or some dumb dance thing. Sean, we don't need to, the next sentence
“你们需要DJ吗？因为我也当DJ。”其实这不是真的，我根本不会。但他们说：“其实我们还真需要。不过是这样的，在斯图贝克酒吧，每个小时的正点我们都会搞一种叫‘秀场时间’（Showtimes）的活动，所有服务员都会跳上吧台，表演类似‘手摇舞’（hand jive）或者其他什么愚蠢的舞蹈。”肖恩，我们不需要——你嘴里接下来的那句话
out of your mouth doesn't need to be, you mean like this? Like this. Or are they still in business or what are their hours? Address please. Any of those sentences are a no. So you lied, so you lied, but you knew you had a stack of wax in the car.
不需要是：“你是说像这样吗？”“像这样。”或者“他们现在还在营业吗？营业时间是几点？”“请告诉我地址。”以上任何一句话都是绝对不行的。所以你撒谎了，所以你撒谎了，但你知道你的车里有一堆黑胶唱片。
So I lied and they said, well, here's the thing, you got to audition because we do these show times. So I had to audition with a lip sync of a 50s song. Which one? I know you still know it. So I chose Volare. Volare. Yeah, and which was, I just thought it'd be funny
所以我撒谎了，他们说：“好吧，情况是这样的，你得去试镜，因为我们有这个秀场时间。”所以我必须通过对口型假唱一首50年代的歌曲来进行试镜。哪首？我知道你肯定还记得。所以我选了《Volare》。《Volare》。
because it's in Italian. But I put on a tuxedo and a pompadour to cover my long hair. Like an Elvis wig, right? And so anyway, I got the job, and then they saw that I had really long hair, and they said, you gotta cut your hair. We're a 50s bar, not a 60s bar. And I said, well, I won't do it.
对，我觉得这应该挺逗的，因为它是意大利语的。我穿了一套燕尾服，还弄了个蓬巴杜发型（pompadour）来遮住我的长发。就像一个猫王假发，对吧？不管怎样，我得到了这份工作，然后他们发现我其实留着一头长发，就对我说：“你得把头发剪了。我们这是50年代的酒吧，不是60年代的酒吧。”我说：“好吧，我才不剪呢。”
So they made me wear the Elvis wig every time I worked. Oh right. You wore the pompadour every time? Yeah, and it was also a really bad pompadour. So it was a really cheap wig and so it started to lose its pompadour shape and it just turned into like a big, weird black tuft of something.
所以他们逼我每次上班都戴着那个猫王假发。哦，对了。你每次上班都戴着蓬巴杜假发？对，而且那还是个质量极差的蓬巴杜假发。那是个很便宜的假发，所以它开始失去蓬巴杜的发型形状，最后直接变成了一团巨大、诡异的黑色乱发。
And when I was working, people didn't realize that I had long hair and had to cover it up. So they just thought I was some young kid with this weird wig. I don't know what they thought. But anyway, that started my DJing career. And then-
当我工作的时候，人们并没有意识到我其实是一头长发并把它藏了起来。所以他们以为我只是个顶着这个诡异假发的年轻小伙。我不知道他们在想什么。不管怎样，那就开启了我的DJ生涯。然后——
You know what, it reminds me, you make me think, you hear about famously Michael Jordan when he had his Hall of Fame speech, and then he's being celebrated for being the greatest basketball player. And then he really harped on his high school coach who cut him from the basketball team and all the people who didn't, right?
你知道吗，这让我想起——你让我想起，大家众所周知的迈克尔·乔丹（Michael Jordan），当他在名人堂发表演讲时，他因为被尊为最伟大的篮球运动员而受到庆祝。然后他却狠狠地数落了高中时把他从篮球队裁掉的教练以及所有那些不看好他的人，对吧？
That he still hung onto that. And I think we should get stickers made up and go around these Kansas City establishments that rejected you. And stick it on the front window. This place rejected Paul Rudd, right? Really let that stink linger on him. You know what I mean?
他一直对那些耿耿于怀。我觉得我们应该制作一些贴纸，去堪萨斯城那些拒绝过你的店铺里，把它贴在正面的玻璃窗上。“这家店曾经拒绝过保罗·路德”，对吧？让这种耻辱感永远留在他们店上。你知道我的意思吗？
Your hiring practices are rudiculous. Yeah, you know what I mean? Are rudiculous, yeah, that's great. Speaking of your original last name was Rudnitsky, what is it? Rudnitsky, down like way back, not while I was born or my grandparents, so they were way back, great-great-grandparents, yeah.
你们的招聘政策太“路”理取闹了（rudiculous）。（译者注：rudiculous为谐音梗，结合了Paul Rudd的名字和ridiculous荒谬）对，你知道我的意思吗？太“路”理取闹了，对，这太棒了。说到你原本的姓氏是鲁德尼斯基（Rudnitsky），到底是什么？鲁德尼斯基，那是很久很久以前的事了，不是我出生时或者我祖父母那辈，那是更久远的曾曾祖父母辈了，对吧。
Wow. Polish? Like Russian, Belarus, Eastern European, yeah. Wow. Polish? Like Russian, Belarus, Eastern European, yeah. Have you done the thing where you do the whole look back and like, do you know your people? What they did, where they were, the wars they fought in? And I found that it was mainly kind of like in an area of Belarus.
哇。波兰血统？就像俄罗斯、白俄罗斯、东欧那边，对吧。哇。波兰血统？就像俄罗斯、白俄罗斯、东欧那边，对吧。你做过那种寻根溯源的基因检测吗，比如了解你的祖先？他们做过什么，去过哪儿，打过什么仗？我发现那大概是在白俄罗斯的一个地区。
Yeah, something called, a town called Holmec. Anybody who's listening from Holmec. Holler at your boy. But now wait, so Paul, let me tell you if I got this right. You were born in Jersey, moved to Kansas City, had a bar mitzvah in Canada, your parents were from England. Yeah. So you were all over the place. Bar mitzvah in Canada, your parents were from England. Yeah.
对，有个地方叫——一个叫霍梅克（Holmec）的小镇。任何正在收听节目的、来自霍梅克的朋友。给你们的小伙子打个招呼吧。不过等等，保罗，让我理理看我有没有弄错。你出生在新泽西，搬到了堪萨斯城，在加拿大办了犹太成人礼，你的父母来自英国。对。所以你到处搬家。在加拿大办了犹太成人礼，父母来自英国。对。
So you went all over the place. Bar mitzvah in Canada, now I'm interested. Yeah. I mean, why so many different places? Well, being, you know, everyone in my family was kind of, was British, both my parents, everyone was kind of around London, my grandparents were in London,
所以你去过好多地方。在加拿大办了犹太成人礼，这下我感兴趣了。我的意思是，为什么搬过这么多地方？好吧，因为——你知道的，我家里每个人基本上都是英国人，我父母双方都是，大家都在伦敦附近，我的祖父母也在伦敦，
but we moved to the States, and then, or my parents did anyway. Most of the family went to Canada. And so I had grandparents and aunts and uncle in Toronto and in the GTA. No, he really knows it. I know. Is that right, eh?
但我们搬到了美国，或者说我父母搬了过去。家族里的大多数人都去了加拿大。所以我有多伦多以及大多伦多地区（GTA）的祖父母、姨妈和叔叔。他居然真的知道。我知道。是这样吗，诶？
Oh man. The way he said Toronto too, this is real. Yeah. I'd walk to the byway, get my Empire Strikes Back cards, in French. Yes. The Byway.
哦天哪。他连“多伦多”的发音都那么地道，这是动真格的了。对。我会走到小路（byway）去买我的《帝国反击战》卡片，法语版的。没错。小路。
Are you still a Maple Leaf fan? Past the Mr. Sub Marine. This is all for you, Will. This is such good stuff, Pizza, Pizza, 967. It's Mr. Sub though, isn't it? Mr. Sub, it's now Mr. Sub. Did you live in Canada? No, but I'd been going there my whole life.
你现在还是枫叶队（Maple Leaf）的球迷吗？路过美达子潜艇堡（Mr. Submarine）。这一切都是为你准备的，威尔。这些料太棒了，披萨比萨，967。那是Mr. Sub吧，对不对？Mr. Sub，现在叫Mr. Sub。你在加拿大住过吗？没有，但我一辈子都在那儿来来回回。
Yeah, so. Wow. And so most of my relatives were in Canada. So when I had to get a bar mitzvah, my parents said, well, just do it in Canada because that's where most of the family is. Where was it in Canada? In Toronto? In Toronto, yeah.
对，所以。哇。所以我的大部分亲戚都在加拿大。所以当我需要办犹太成人礼时，我父母说：“好吧，那就直接去加拿大办吧，因为大部分亲戚都在那儿。”那是在加拿大的哪儿？多伦多？在多伦多，对。
No way. Paul, come home. Come home. Sure. By the way, great, yeah. I will. So your parents are in England, your dad was a tour guide or something,
不会吧。保罗，回家吧。欢迎回家。当然。顺便说一句，太棒了，对。我会的。所以你父母在英国，你爸爸是个导游什么的，
and was the vice president of TWA, and your mom? Oh no, he wasn't the vice president, that would have been nice. No, he did work for TWA. TWA was the airline, TWA, their hub was in Kansas City, which is why we wound up in Kansas City. Got it, got it, got it. When my dad left London when he was a kid, he was about nine years old,
曾任环球航空（TWA）的副总裁，还有你妈妈？哦不，他可不是副总裁，要是那样就好了。不，他确实为环球航空工作过。环球航空是一家航空公司，TWA，他们的枢纽在堪萨斯城，这就是为什么我们最后落脚在堪萨斯城的原因。明白了，明白了，明白了。我爸爸小时候离开伦敦时，他大概九岁，
and then they moved to New Jersey, his family, and they were in Patterson, New Jersey. But he eventually started working with TWA before I was born. to New Jersey, his family, and they were in Patterson, New Jersey. But he eventually started working with TWA before I was born, and he kept getting job transfers. So we moved around a lot when I was a kid. I was born in New Jersey, and then I lived in New Jersey, and then I moved to Kansas for about a year, and then I moved to California for a few years, and then I moved back to Kansas. So we moved around quite a bit.
然后他们全家搬到了新泽西，住在新泽西州的帕特森。但在我出生之前，他最终开始在环球航空工作。新泽西，他们住在新泽西州的帕特森。但自我出生前起，他一直在环球航空工作，而且他不断调动工作岗位。所以在我小时候我们搬了很多次家。我出生在新泽西，然后我住在新泽西，接着我搬到堪萨斯住了大约一年，然后我又搬到加利福尼亚住了几年，接着又搬回了堪萨斯。所以我们确实搬了不少次家。
What about all the moving around and stuff? Was there like, it's giving me anxiety. All the schools and all the kids. Oh, look at the new kid. Did you guys, when you grew, did you grow up in one spot? Yes. Did you always, I mean, Jason, you were always LA, right?
关于经常搬家这些事，有没有——这让我感到焦虑。所有的学校和所有的小孩。哦，看那个新来的孩子。你们，你们在成长过程中，是在一个地方长大的吗？是的。你们一直——我的意思是，杰森，你一直在洛杉矶，对吧？
Since I was seven, I've been in Los Angeles, yeah. Where were you before that? I was in Salt Lake City from four to seven. I was in Boston from two to four, and I was in New York from zero to two. Just outside in Rye. Oh, beautiful. But what about you adapting
我从七岁起就一直在洛杉矶了，对。那之前你在哪儿？我四岁到七岁在盐湖城。我两岁到四岁在波士顿，零岁到两岁在纽约。就在郊区的莱伊（Rye）。哦，太美了。那你呢，你是怎么适应
into all those different environments? Did you have a sibling to sort of protect you, or did you do the protecting? I have a younger sister. She's two and a half years younger than me. And I think, yeah, we always were just kind of the new kids in school. We got very used to it.
所有那些不同的环境的？你有一个弟弟妹妹来保护你，还是你反过来保护别人？我有一个妹妹。她比我小两岁半。我觉得，对，我们总是理所当然地成为学校里的新面孔。我们对此习以为常。
We didn't really know any different. But like, did that shape your, at an age where you're kind of learning your personality and kind of what your strong suit is and what isn't, you know, are you funny, are you... Like, did you find that you were, perhaps made you nicer earlier because you had to be accepted
我们并不觉得有什么不同。但是，这有没有塑造你的——在那个正在学习塑造你的人格、确定你的长处和短处所在的年纪，你知道的，你是否幽默，你是否……比如，你有没有发现，或许这让你变得更早熟、更随和，因为你不得不一直被这些新群体所接纳？
by these new groups all the time? Uh-huh, yeah. Possibly. I, yeah, I sometimes think that, you know, a good way to kind of ingratiate yourself or just not get your ass kicked is to just be kind of pleasant and if you can make somebody laugh, then you can be accepted a little bit easier.
嗯——哼，对。有可能。我，对，我有时觉得，融入集体或者说不挨揍的一个好方法，就是表现得随和一点，如果你能逗别人笑，那么你就能更容易被大家接受。
I certainly was drawn and always have been drawn to people who are funny. I mean, my dad was hilarious. And I think that when I'd be probably in some new school or something, I'd go home and I'd listen to those Steve Martin records. You had that album, Get Small, did you ever listen to that? Yeah. What about British humor?
我确实被那些幽默的人吸引，而且一直都是如此。我的意思是，我父亲太搞笑了。我想，当我可能置身于某个新学校或类似的地方时，我回到家就会去听那些史蒂夫·马丁的唱片。你有那张专辑《Get Small》吗，你听过吗？听过。那英国幽默呢？
Because my mom's British as well, and she really shaped my taste in dry, kind of no-winking, you know, humor. Did your dad do that for you? Well, I think that, you know, some of the earliest things I can really remember laughing at was they used to show Monty Python's Flying Circus on PBS. Yeah, loved it.
因为我妈妈也是英国人，她确实塑造了我对那种干巴巴的、不带俏皮暗示的幽默的品味。你爸爸对你也有这种影响吗？嗯，我觉得，你知道的，我最早真正记得能让我发笑的事情之一，就是他们在PBS（公共电视网）上播放的《巨蟒剧团之飞翔的马戏团》（Monty Python's Flying Circus）。对，超级喜欢。
And my parents loved it and we'd watch it and I thought it was hilarious. I never really understood or thought in terms of like British comedy comedy or British sensibility, but I did always respond to that. And then when Faulty Towers was on, it was just more of a scene of them all the time. But it's like, you know, Monty Python's a great example.
我父母也超喜欢，我们一起看，我觉得太搞笑了。我从来没有真正从英国喜剧或英国情调的角度去理解或思考，但我总是对那种风格作出反应。后来当《费城小子》（Faulty Towers，译者注：应为《 Fawlty Towers 飞跃疯人院/塔楼》）播出时，那更是我们经常看的场景。但就像，你知道的，《巨蟒剧团》就是一个很好的例子。
Oh, holy shit. There's no way. You guys like Faulty Towers? Sean, Sean, you really like that? Fucking let the world know, man. Yeah, you guys like faulty towers Sean you really like that fucking let the world know man. Yeah There's but like Monty Python there's like there's the broad half of the of the troop and then there's like the dry half of The troop like there's Michael Palin, you know being crazy and goofy and then you cut to John Cleese and he's just blinking at him Like you fool
哦，操。不可能。你们也喜欢《费城小子》？肖恩，肖恩，你真的很喜欢那个？让全世界都知道吧，老兄。对，你们喜欢《费城小子》，肖恩，你真的很喜欢那个？让全世界都知道吧，老兄。对。但就像《巨蟒剧团》里那样，剧团里有一半人是夸张搞笑的，另一半则是那种一本正经、干巴巴的风格——比如迈克尔·帕林（Michael Palin），你知道的，既疯狂又滑稽，然后镜头一切到约翰·克利斯（John Cleese），他只是眨巴着眼睛看着对方，就像在说“你这个傻瓜”。
It's which which were you drawn to was was it the John Cleese side since you went to faulty towers? and he's just blinking at him like you fool. Which were you drawn to? Was it the John Cleese side since you went to Faulty Towers? Well, Cleese is always hilarious. I think that, I think I just, there was an absurdity to it. And there was also something, it might have been the first time, maybe why I was drawn to Steve Martin as well,
你更被哪一种吸引？是因为你提到了《费城小子》，所以你更倾向于约翰·克利斯那一挂吗？他只是眨巴着眼睛看着对方，就像在说“你这个傻瓜”。你更被哪一种吸引？是因为你提到了《费城小子》，所以你更倾向于约翰·克利斯那一挂吗？好吧，克利斯总是那么搞笑。我觉得，我觉得我只是——里面有一种荒诞感。而且还有某种东西，可能这也是为什么我被史蒂夫·马丁吸引的原因，
but it was like, oh my God, there are grownups that are being completely silly. I remember that twit of the year competition as a kid and crying, I couldn't believe how funny it was to see these grownups acting this way. And I mean, there was still so much with, same with Steve Martin, where it was this kind of, ridiculous, I'm getting was this kind of ridiculous,
但那就像是：“哦，天哪，竟然有成年人可以表现得如此彻底的幼稚滑稽。”我小时候看那个“年度白痴”比赛时感动得哭了，我简直不敢相信看到这些成年人做出这种举止会这么好笑。我的意思是，里面依然有很多，史蒂夫·马丁也是一样，那种——荒谬绝伦的，我当时——那种荒谬绝伦的。
I'm getting happy feet kind of thing. I want to know about glazing hams, because that was one of your odd jobs out of school. What do you mean glazing hams? What does that even mean? It means exactly, it means glazing hams. Yeah, like what does that, what do you mean? Did you work at Honey Baked Ham?
我有点坐立不安了。我想了解一下火腿是怎么刷糖浆的，因为那是你毕业后做过的奇葩工作之一。你说的刷糖浆是什么意思？那到底是什么意思？字面意思，就是给火腿刷糖浆。对啊，那到底是什么意思？你是在蜜汁火腿店（Honey Baked Ham）工作过吗？
No, that was our competitor. Sorry, sorry. No, no, what do you mean glazing them though? Oh, it's still touchy. Yeah. The hot spot. Look, it's just please don't bring that up to anyone at Holiday Ham Company because they had a real issue with Honey Bakes. Wait, but how do you glaze a ham? Like, what do you do? It's a whole process, Sean. Let's keep it clean here. Sounds like a YouTube how-to video. How do you clean that? Is it like in a factory?
不，那是我们的竞争对手。抱歉，抱歉。不，不，那你说的刷糖浆到底是什么意思？哦，这还是个敏感话题。对啊。火热的话题。听着，千万别在假日火腿公司（Holiday Ham Company）的人面前提起这个，因为他们和蜜汁火腿（Honey Bake）之间有过很大的过节。等等，那你怎么给火腿刷糖浆？就是，具体怎么做？这可是一套完整的流程，肖恩。咱们在这儿聊点干净的吧。听起来像是个YouTube的教程视频。这东西怎么清洗？是在工厂里吗？
No, no, it was in like a mini-mall. And... Oh, I see, like personalized tamp. It was like a standalone store. Oh, got it, okay. I believe it's a chain, isn't it? Okay, got it. I just wanted to know.
不，不，是在那种小型购物中心里。然后……哦，我明白了，就像个性化定制的那种。就像是一家独立的门店。哦，明白了，好吧。我想它应该是个连锁店吧？好吧，懂了。我就是想了解一下。
I mean, by the way, I don't mean to besmirch Honey Bait. No, for sure. No, no, no, no, no. Nobody took it that way. No, no, no, no. Oh, thanks. I think it was a public company, by the way. There's one thing I don't want to know. I don't mean to besmirch Honey Baked. No, no, no, nobody took it that way. No, no, no. I think it was a public company. There's one thing I don't want to do. It's piss off the people at Honey Baked. No, Paul, you don't have a target on your back now.
我的意思是，顺便说一句，我可不是存心想诋毁蜜汁（Honey Bait）。不，当然不是。不，不，不，不，不。没人会这么想。不，不，不，不。哦，谢谢。我觉得它是一家上市公司吧，顺便说一句。有一件事我是绝对不想做的。我可不是想诋毁蜜汁火腿。不，不，不，没人会那么想。不，不，不。我觉得它是一家上市公司。有一件事我是绝对不想做的。那就是惹恼蜜汁火腿的人。不，保罗，你现在背后可没有靶子。
Don't worry. The gang over at Honey Glazed. Okay. So, yeah, go ahead. Oh, no, no. What do you love? No, you go. What are you going to say? Guys, don't play do you love? No, you go, you go. What are you gonna say?
别担心。那边蜜汁糖霜（Honey Glazed）的人。好吧。所以，行，你接着说。哦，不，不。你最喜欢什么？不，你先说。你刚才想说什么？各位，别在这儿推来推去了。不，你先说，你先说。你刚才想说什么？
Guys, don't play. All right. I was gonna- You go. Oh, Jesus. No, you go. This is a great bit. Please.
各位，别闹了。好吧。我本来想——你先说。哦，天哪。不，你先说。这个梗太棒了。求你了。
It is a great bit. It's the new Laurel and Hardy. I wanna know where you worked. I wanna know where you worked. Oh. I worked at Holiday Ham Company. That was the name of it. No, you were gonna say something else about working.
这梗确实棒。简直就是新时代的劳 Laurel and Hardy（劳雷尔和哈迪）。我想知道你在哪儿工作过。我想知道你在哪儿工作过。哦。我在假日火腿公司工作过。那就是它的名字。不对，你刚才本来要说点别的关于工作的事。
So I worked at this place, and it was a whole, when I say it was a whole process, I would get there very early in the morning, and I would unload a truck filled with ham. Naked hams. These aren't glazed yet, right? These are unglazed. Oh, you're talking unglazed hams.
所以我曾在那个地方工作，那是一整套，我说这是一整套流程，我每天清晨得去得很早，然后我要卸一卡车的火腿。赤裸裸的火腿。这些还没刷糖浆吧？对吧？这些都是没刷过糖浆的。哦，你指的是没刷糖浆的火腿。
Yeah, all hams. By the way, this isn't like pigs hanging in a truck. These were ham hocks, are they hocks? They can be, sure. And they were cryovact, vacuum sealed. Oh wow. And what I would have to do is unload a truck at like five in the morning,
对，全都是火腿。顺便说一句，这可不是那种挂在卡车里的整只猪。这些都是火腿肘子，是肘子吗？也可以是，当然。而且它们都是用真空塑封膜封好的。哦，哇。我要做的是在差不多清晨五点的时候卸卡车，
and then I would have to cut open. Release them from their sheaths? Yes, exactly, cut open the plastic. And then I would have to put them, these entire ham hocks. So far, I haven't heard one thing that we're gonna keep in the episode, but go ahead. Yeah, no, no, this is absolutely,
然后我得切开。把它们从包装鞘里解放出来？对，没错，切开塑料包装。然后我得把它们放进去，这些整只火腿肘子。到目前为止，我还没听到一件能在节目里播出的内容，不过你接着说。对，不，不，这绝对是，
it's boring myself as I even listen to myself describe it. So there you are, you're unloading. You got a truck full of unblased hands. So I gotta put it on a thing, I slice it, I dice out a whole thing, I gotta cut it in half with a saw, I put it on a spit, and then I take a propane torch and a sugar sifter, and I have to wear protective gear on my wrists.
连我自己听着自己描述都觉得烦。所以你就这样，你在卸货。你有一卡车没刷糖浆的火腿。然后我得把它放到一个台子上，切片，把整块东西切成小块，我得用锯子把它锯成两半，把它架在烤叉上，然后我拿一个丙烷喷枪和一个糖粉筛，而且我的手腕上还得戴着防护装备。
Same approach to acting. Same approach to your acting. That's exactly right. That is how I approach all on my wrists. Same approach to acting. Same approach to your acting. That's exactly right. That is how I approach all of my roles. And how long, were you longer in this job than you were at the Bevex place, the 50s joint? Studebakers. Yeah, Studebakers.
演戏也是这套路。演戏也是这路子。完全正确。我所有的角色都是这么处理的。那你在那份工作干了多久，比你在那个叫贝维克斯（Bevex）的50年代复古餐厅干得还久吗？斯蒂德贝克（Studebakers）。对，斯蒂德贝克。
I went from Studebakers to Holiday Ham Company. So, you know. Did you cut your hair before you were handling those hams? Sorry, can I ask, did you have the long hair when you were handling the hams, or did you have hair? Yeah, they didn't care. They didn't care. You had to put that shit in a net, though, didn't you?
我从斯蒂德贝克跳槽到了假日火腿公司。所以呢。你处理那些火腿之前剪头发了吗？抱歉，我能问一下吗，你处理火腿的时候留着长发吗，还是说你压根有头发？对，他们不在乎。他们不在乎。你得把那些恶心的头发网起来吧，对不对？
By the way, I think I had it in a net. Yeah. And, um. Net the hair. Yeah. It was in a net, I was in the back. So, if I was up front, dealing with customers, there's no way they'd allow it.
顺便说一句，我想我是用发网网起来了。对，而且，嗯。把头发网住。对。塞在发网里，我在后厨。所以如果我去前台接待顾客的话，他们绝对是不允许的。
You snapped that off. Yeah. There's no way they'd allow. Now, I can only imagine though, you know at least one or two of those long hairs were getting glazed into the ham. I just thought it would be a good Italian place called I Can Only Imagine, it's just cannolis. It's terrible, it's terrible stuff, it's Saturday.
你把那个断句了。对。他们绝对不允许。不过我只能想象，你知道至少有一两根长头发被裹进火腿的糖浆里了吧。我刚才还以为那会是一家叫“我只能想象”的意式餐厅，里面只卖奶油甜馅卷。太糟糕了，这简直是烂透了，今天是星期六。
It's Saturday and it's terrible. It's terrible stuff. It's Saturday. It's Saturday and it's free. And it's free. So go ahead, Sean. Sean, get to your laundry list of questions and forget trying to have a conversation with Paul Rudd. Go down and fucking check off your fucking... We've got Paul fucking Rudd here. He's one of the most handsome. By the way, Paul, and I've seen it in stuff before, you always look so fucking good. You're so handsome. You're so handsome.
今天是星期六，而且这简直太烂了。这东西太烂了。今天是星期六。今天是星期六，而且是免费的。而且是免费的。所以你接着说，肖恩。肖恩，快去完成你那长长的问题清单吧，别总想着跟保罗·路德聊天了。快去完成你那该死的……我们这可是请到了保罗·路德大驾光临。他是最帅的男演员之一。顺便说一句，保罗，我以前在其他地方也看过，你总是看起来这么帅。你太帅了。你真的太帅了。
You're so good. We're around the same age. What are you doing? Just honestly, just an email with a couple tips. Olive oil bag. Eight hours a day. You say the most important thing is eight hours a day. That's what you say.
你状态太好了。我们年纪差不多。你到底是怎么保养的？老实说，能不能发封邮件分享几个秘诀。橄榄油面膜。一天八小时。你说最重要的是每天睡够八小时。你是这么说的。
It isn't what I say. I think I said something about sleep once where it was like, oh yeah, this is, you try and get enough sleep. I sleep a lot. I don't look anything like you. Can I, you know what the secret is? What?
这不是我说的。我想我以前大概提过一次睡眠，就那种，哦对，就是，你尽量保证充足的睡眠。我觉挺多的。我长得可一点都不像你。要不，你知道秘诀是什么吗？什么？
Love. Yeah, Julie. Oh my God. That's our time, that's our time. Who knew? Love and laughter. You saved a name, Julie will have you back now. Who knew? This is, ugh. We'll be right back.
爱。对，朱莉。哦天哪。我们的时间到了，时间到了。谁能想到呢？爱与欢笑。你总算挽回了局面，朱莉以后还会让你上节目的。谁能想到呢？这，呃。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. No, seriously, Paul, anything weird ever happen on stage, And now back to the show. No, seriously, Paul, anything weird ever happen on stage real quick before we're out of time? No, no, no. Well, yeah, you did a lot of theater. I don't know if you listen to the podcast, but I love good theater stories where something's wrong. Oh, of course.
欢迎回到节目中。说真的，保罗，在节目快要结束之前，你在舞台上有没有遇到过什么诡异的事？不，不，不。好吧，对，你演过很多戏剧。我不知道你有没有听过这个播客，但我特别喜欢那种出了状况的好玩戏剧故事。哦，当然。
Yeah, I do. And yes. You got everything ready? Or you can sub it out for a Star Wars story if you ever audition for it. No, I have lots of other questions. Of great theater stories? Yeah, yeah, something bad happened in the theater.
对，我喜欢。而且没错。你都准备好了吗？或者你也可以换成一个《星球大战》的故事，如果你曾经去试镜过的话。不，我还有很多其他问题。都是关于精彩的戏剧故事？对，对，就是戏剧里发生过什么不好的事。
Oh, something really bad, yeah. No, no, I've had, I actually, well, I've done a show where somebody died in the audience. On stage, oh, in the audience. There was a death, there was a death in the audience. There was somebody went to the bathroom in like the fourth row. That was an interesting thing.
哦，非常糟糕的事，对。不，不，我经历过，实际上，嗯，我演过一出戏，有观众在台下直接去世了。在舞台上，哦，是在观众席。观众席里死人了。观众席里发生了一起死亡事件。有个观众在差不多第四排的地方上了个厕所。那可真是个有趣的状况。
We get a whiff of that during the scene. No way. Somebody lost control of their bowels. So not only did you kill, but you acted the shit out of that part. Nice. Bravo! Thanks guys.
我们在演戏的时候还闻到了一阵味儿。不会吧。有人失禁了。所以你不仅炸裂全场（killed），而且你还把那部分演得（拉）屎都出来了（acted the shit out of that part）。太棒了。太精彩了！谢谢你们。
Well it wasn't me that did it. Oh. Yeah. No, that would be, actually that would be, that would be horrible. Wait, what was the show, and somebody really died? Somebody died last night of Ballyhoo was the show. These were two separate occasions.
好吧，拉裤子的人可不是我。哦。对。不，那样的话，其实那会，那会太糟糕了。等等，那是哪部戏，真的有人死了？那部戏叫《巴利胡的最后日子》（The Last Night of Ballyhoo）。这是两起不同的事件。
Unless I'm conflating them and they shit themselves and then they die. Because that often happens. By the way, it's often, I think it even happens in the other order where it's like you die and then you wind up just shitting yourself. That's the shape that happens. So wait, so the person died. I've had somebody, by the way,
除非我把它们搞混了——他们先是拉了裤子，然后又死了。因为这事儿经常发生。顺便说一句，这经常发生，我觉得甚至可能是反着来的，就是你先死了，接着发现自己顺便把裤子给拉了。事情通常是这样的。所以等等，那个人死了。我曾经历过，顺便说一句，
I've also done a show where somebody in the middle of a scene, I heard a bunch of commotion in the audience and then didn't realize, it didn't subside. So I was like, what is happening? Only later came to realize that somebody in the front row of the balcony leaned over and puked on all of the people below.
我还演过一出戏，就在演到某个场景的时候，我听到观众席里传来一阵骚动，然后当时没意识到，这动静一直没平息下来。所以我就想，到底发生什么事了？直到后来才知道，原来是阳台最前排的一个人探出身子，朝下面所有的人身上吐了呕吐物。
Oh my God. No way. No way. Swear to God. Yeah. It was a show called Grace. And there's a scene, and I was doing it with Michael Shannon.
哦天哪。不会吧。真的假的。发誓真的。对。那是一部叫《恩典》（Grace）的戏。里面有个场景，我和迈克尔·香农（Michael Shannon）一起演。
No way. And Michael Shannon had this long monologue. We're doing the scene. It's just the two of us. We hear this noise. We're both aware that there's a commotion, but usually it dies down and it's getting louder and louder and Michael is pissed off and starts screaming his lines
不会吧。迈克尔·香农当时有一段很长的独白。我们正在演那场戏。就我们俩。然后我们听到了这个声音。我们都意识到有骚动发生，但通常这种声音很快就会平息，而这次却越来越大，迈克尔气坏了，开始冲着声音传来的方向
at toward the direction of the noise. To make a point. Which of course when Michael Shannon is yelling at you, like it's the most terrifying thing ever. It's the thing that did make everybody kind of quiet down. And then after this scene, I have to rush over to the wings to do a costume change, and I asked the stage manager. I said, what the hell's hap- what happened out there?
大声吼出他的台词。以此来强调。当然啦，当迈克尔·香农冲你大吼大叫的时候，那简直是世上最吓人的事了。这招确实让所有人都安静了下来。接着在那场戏演完后，我得赶紧冲到后台侧幕去换服装，我问舞台经理。我说，到底怎么了——外面发生什么事了？
And he's the one that said somebody threw up, somebody was drunk and threw up over the balcony and it puked onto about 10 different people. I'm covered in barf! This show's not for you, huh? Fucking bad todays! That's amazing. Should've seen the lion king! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
然后就是他告诉我，有人吐了，有个喝醉的人从阳台吐了出来，呕吐物吐了大概十多个人一身。我满身都是呕吐物！这节目不适合你，对吧？真他妈的倒霉！太惊艳了。你们真该去看看《狮子王》！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！
Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！
Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God! Oh, my God like, oh my God. They had to close down and then eventually they had to bring somebody, like a stretcher,
哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！哦，天哪！比如，哦天哪。他们不得不中断演出，最后还不得不弄来担架，
they'd get somebody out of there. It's like, oh wow. Wow. It's weird, I mean, you hear of people dying on stage. Yeah. But you don't hear as much about people dying near the stage. Yeah, yeah.
把人给抬出去了。当时就觉得，哦哇。哇。说来也怪，我的意思是，你经常听说有人在舞台上猝死的。对。但你很少听说有人在舞台旁边死的。对，对。
But did you, so you stopped the show, yeah? You stopped and they, right? We did not stop. You didn't keep going. You kept going? I don't think, did you keep going? Dude, are you kidding? and they, right? We did not stop. You didn't keep going. You kept going? I don't think, dude, you kept going. Dude, are you kidding? Are you kidding?
不过你，所以你们把演出停了，对吧？你们停下来了，然后呢？我们没有停。你们没继续演下去吗？你们继续演了？我记不清了，你们继续演了吗？老兄，你在开玩笑吧？他们停下来了，对吧？我们没有停。你们没继续演下去吗？你们继续演了？我才不信，老兄，你们继续演了。老兄，你在开玩笑吧？开什么玩笑？
He fucking, he killed. By the way, died. The guy. We slayed him. Yeah, died nearing the end of the show. Yeah. And, I'm not so sure, anyone realized. Oh wow.
他妈的，他死得太精彩了。顺便说一句，死了。那个观众。我们把全场“炸”翻了。对，就在演出快结束时咽了气。对。而且，我甚至不确定，当时有没有人意识到。哦，哇。
Until. Until it was over? Until people were shuffling out of the theater at one guy's stage. Sounds like a nice peaceful passing. Yeah. It was definitely a courteous way to go. For us, for the actors.
直到。直到演出结束？直到人们开始陆陆续续离开剧院时，有个家伙在台下才发现。听起来走得很安详啊。对。对我们、对演员们来说，这绝对是一种很有礼貌的离开方式。
That's great. Now, Sean, I know you have plenty. I've told, I think I've told every single good one. I know. On here. Is there one you haven't told yet? I mean, I'd have to think about it. Me and Reina are at the dinner theater.
太棒了。那么，肖恩，我知道你有很多。我觉得我已经把所有精彩的故事都讲过了。我懂的。就在这儿。有没有哪个故事你还没讲过？我是说，我得想想。我和雷娜在晚餐剧场。
Yeah, right. I've had, by the way, I had one. Now they're all kind of coming, they're flooding back. I did a scene, I was lying on top of a bed. I was doing a scene, I was lying on top of a bed, and I'm with this woman, Rachel Weisz was in the show, and I was wearing boxer shorts and a t-shirt, and all of a sudden, this had never happened before,
对，没错。顺便说一句，我有一个。现在它们都涌上心头了，全记忆犹新了。我曾演过一场戏，我躺在一张床上。我当时在演一场戏，躺在床上，搭档是个女演员，蕾切尔·薇兹（Rachel Weisz）也参演了那部戏，我当时穿着平角短裤和一件T恤，突然间，以前从来没发生过这种事，
I heard the audience laughing. And I'm like, what is going on? I realized it's because I was lying on the bed, I had my leg up and kind of like, and I realized my balls were hanging out. No. Wow. Wait.
我听到台下观众在大笑。我就想，怎么回事？我突然意识到是因为我躺在床上，把一条腿抬了起来，然后大概就那个姿势，接着我发现我的蛋蛋露在外面了。不会吧。哇。等等。
Which is worse than actually, like even your penis. It's like when it's just your balls. Or just one ball. By the way, it might've been just one ball, but it was loose fitting boxers. You know what's crazy about that? You know what's crazy about that? Your balls were showing in that show and the show was loose fitting boxers. You know what's crazy about that? Yeah. You know what's crazy about that?
这比别的还要糟，甚至比你的丁丁露出来还糟。就那种光剩两颗蛋蛋露在外面的情况。或者只露了一颗蛋蛋。顺便说一句，可能当时只露了一颗蛋蛋，不过那条平角短裤比较宽松。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？你那场演出里蛋蛋露出来了，而那部戏的名字叫《性事底牌》（The Shape of Things）。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？对。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？
Your balls were showing in that show and the show was the shape of things. Yeah. Yep, that's exactly right. Nice. That's exactly right. That was your show. Yeah, good.
你那场演出里蛋蛋露出来了，而那部戏就叫《性事底牌》。对。没错，完全正确。太棒了。完全正确。那就是你的戏。对，很好。
The shape of things. Yeah, that's nice. They were pendulous. I have one that's not as race-y as that. The shape of things, it should have been, and the poster should have been your balls hanging out of your shorts. I think we've all seen the shape of those things.
《性事底牌》。对，挺好的。它们晃里晃荡的。我还有一个没那么带颜色的故事。《性事底牌》这部剧原本应该，海报就该直接印你从短裤里露出来的蛋蛋。我想我们大家都见识过那些东西的“形状”了。
With the great Fred Weller, with our mutual friend Fred Weller whom we adore. Great Fred Weller. You guys go back. Do you... What's another one in my mind is that we were doing West Side Story, this isn't as funny, but we were doing West Side Story and the Jets and the Sharks and we then negotiate the rumble. They say knives, guns, pipes, fists, whatever.
和伟大的弗雷德·韦勒（Fred Weller）一起，还有我们共同的朋友弗雷德·韦勒，我们都深爱着他。伟大的弗雷德·韦勒。你们俩交情很深。你……我脑子里的另一个故事是，我们当时在演《西区故事》，这个没那么搞笑，但我们当时在演《西区故事》，喷气帮（Jets）和鲨鱼帮（Sharks）正在商量火拼的事。他们说要用刀、枪、水管、拳头，随便什么都行。
And this one guy, Darren. Dance! Yeah, well, you just blew the joke. But, uh, ah, ah, ah,
然后这个叫达伦的家伙。跳舞！对，好吧，你把包袱全抖落了。不过，呃，啊，啊，啊，
but no, it's like that. So Darren, Darren, my friend Darren, who's the most gayest man on the face of the planet and wears it with a badge of honor. He's very, very, very funny. But he was a Jet and he's trying to act tough. And during performance 250, they go, guns, knives, very, very funny. But he was a jet and he's trying to act tough. And during performance 250, they go guns, knives, pipes, fists, and he just jumps out and he goes, parses.
不过不，就像那样。所以达伦，达伦，我的朋友达伦，他是地球上最gay的男人，而且他把这当成一种荣誉徽章。他非常非常非常搞笑。但他演的是个喷气帮成员，他得装得很强硬。在演到第250场的时候，他们台词说的是，枪、刀、水管、拳头，非常非常搞笑。但他演的是个喷气帮，还得装强硬。在第250场演出时，他们说的是枪、刀、水管、拳头，结果他直接跳出来大喊：芭蕾舞剧！
Same joke, same joke as dance. No, I guess. It's funny, he had to be there, he had to be there. All right, so listen, when you're scrolling through, because you've been in, I want to go through before you leave, I just want, I mean, oh my God, I had all these things. You're in an hour 10, let this guy get back into his weekend. I know, sorry, Wild Oats and Clueless.
同一个包袱，和跳舞是同一个包袱。不，我猜吧。很好笑，你得在现场才行，你得在现场。好吧，听着，当你浏览这些的时候，因为你演过，我希望在你离开前过一遍，我是说，哦天哪，我有这么多东西要说。你已经播了一个小时十分钟了，让这哥们儿好好过个周末吧。我知道，抱歉，还有《荒野百合》（Wild Oats）和《独领风骚》（Clueless）。
No, but his credits, your credits are fucking sick. A wet, hot American summer, and Friends, you run on Friends, there's Anchorman, by the way, and then 40-year-old Virgin and Knocked Up, and working with Jed Apatow, and role models, and Ant-Man that you wrote, I didn't know you wrote Ant-Man. That's crazy. No shit, I didn't know that.
不，不过他的演艺履历，你的履历简直牛逼惨了。《热辣夏日》（Wet Hot American Summer）、《老友记》，你还演了《老友记》，还有《王牌播音员》（Anchorman），顺便说一句，接着是《四十岁的老处男》和《一夜大肚》，跟贾德·阿帕图合作，还有《模范贱兄弟》（Role models），以及你自己编剧的《蚁人》，我居然不知道《蚁人》是你写的。这太疯狂了。真的假的，我居然不知道这事。
Yeah. Well, one of them, one of the writers. He was originally written by Edgar Wright, who I just worked with. Who's the best. The best. I love him. We love Edgar.
对。好吧，其中一个编剧。剧本最初是由埃德加·赖特（Edgar Wright）写的，我刚刚跟他合作过。他可是最棒的。最棒的。我超爱他。我们都爱埃德加。
He's a friend of the show. Yeah, he's great. He should come on, Willie. Adore him. Yeah. So wait, what do you expect? I might need to be a two parter. Yeah, I know, there's so many things. I on, Willie. Adore him. Yeah. So wait, what do you expect? I might need to be a two parter. Yeah, I know, there's so many things.
他是节目的老朋友。对，他太棒了。他应该来上节目，威利。超爱他。对。所以等等，你觉得呢？我可能得录成上下集了。对，我知道，有太多东西要聊了。来上节目吧，威利。超爱他。对。所以等等，你觉得呢？我可能得录成上下集了。对，我知道，有太多东西要聊了。
I know, shit. But wait. You get into the fucking credits, it's crazy. I know. But anyway, so friendship though. You don't have to get into my credit, honestly. No, it's incredible. But the people, they want to know, Paul.
我知道，真他妈的。不过等等。你看看你那一长串的演艺履历，太疯狂了。我懂。不过话说回来，谈谈友谊吧。老实说，你其实不用非得去盘点我的履历。不，这太厉害了。不过观众们，他们想知道，保罗。
I know. You know? They want to know about the moments and the movies. I can't believe they didn't even ask him about it. The Apatow years. I mean, you and Judd collaborated on so many of those movies that were huge, seminal comedies that really kind of changed.
我懂。你知道吗？他们想了解那些电影里的高光时刻。我简直不敢相信他们居然都没问他这个。阿帕图时期。我的意思是你和贾德合作了那么多部喜剧电影，那些都是意义重大、具有开创性的喜剧，真的彻底改变了——
But you think about it, at that time, when you guys did 40-Year-Old Virgin, that really changed the trajectory of comedy films. Like, it kind of went into a, it created a whole new lane. Well Jud did it a few times, a great Jud Apatow. He launched all kinds of folks. Yeah, he's great. The first time I ever met Jud was,
但你仔细想想，当时你们拍《四十岁的老处男》的时候，那部电影真的改变了喜剧电影的发展轨迹。就好像它进入了一个，开辟了一条全新的赛道。好吧，贾德确实这么干过好几次，伟大的贾德·阿帕图。他发掘了各种各样的人才。对，他太棒了。我第一次见贾德是在，
it really is a weird thing. I don't know if you guys feel this way about those Steve Martin records. I know we've talked about them a lot. But it seems as if a lot of people in our generation, those albums had a big effect on them. Yeah. Sure, yeah. And as did Steve Martin in general.
这其实是一件很诡异的事。我不知道你们对斯蒂夫·马丁（Steve Martin）的那些喜剧唱片有没有这种感觉。我知道我们以前经常聊这个。但似乎在我们这一代人当中，那些专辑对他们的影响非常大。对。当然，没错。史蒂夫·马丁也是如此。
And one time I was at a dinner and I was talking about fake names and how it's so difficult to come up with a perfect, funny, fake name. And I said a great example is Gern Blanston, which was from an early Steve Martin routine. And someone at the dinner said, Gern Blanston, oh, that explains Judd Apatow's email address.
有一次我参加一个晚宴，当时在聊假名字的事，聊到要构思一个完美、搞笑的假名字有多么困难。然后我说了一个极佳的例子叫“格恩·布兰斯顿”（Gern Blanston），这出自史蒂夫·马丁早期的滑稽表演。晚宴上有个人就说：“格恩·布兰斯顿？哦，这就难怪贾德·阿帕图的邮箱地址是这个了。”
Oh wow. And I think at this time there was only AOL. I'm like, oh, that's hilarious. Yeah, he's like Gern Blanston. I don't think he has this anymore in case anybody wants to email him. But anyway, I went home and emailed Judd. I'd never met him.
哦，哇。而且我记得当时还只有AOL邮箱。我就想：“哦，太搞笑了。”对，他邮箱名就是Gern Blanston。我觉得他现在应该不用这个了，以防有人想给他发邮件。不过总之，我回家后就给贾德发了封邮件。我当时压根没见过他。
No way. And I said, hey man, nice reference on your email address. That's amazing. And he emailed me back. And that's how you guys started to be. And that's amazing. And he emailed me back. And that's how you guys started. And that's how we met. And then he emailed me back and said, oh, I'm glad you've emailed me,
不会吧。我说：“嘿，老兄，你邮箱地址梗用得不错嘛。”这太绝了。然后他回我邮件了。你们俩就是这么开始的。这太酷了。然后他给我回了邮件。你们就是这么开始的。我们就这样认识了。接着他回邮件说：“哦，很高兴你给我发邮件，
it's nice to connect with you. Now I know who to hit up if I ever need tickets to a new Neil Abut play, because I've just done a bunch of Neil Abut plays. Anyway, we kept emailing each other for about a year. We became kind of pen pals, never met each other. And it wasn't until Anchorman that I actually met him in person.
很高兴能和你建立联系。现在我知道如果我以后需要尼尔·拉布特（Neil LaBute）新话剧的门票该找谁了，因为我刚演了一堆尼尔·拉布特的话剧。”总之，我们俩互通邮件差不多有一年之久。我们成了某种笔友，却从未谋面。直到拍《王牌播音员》的时候，我才真正跟他在现实中见了面。
Oh wow, that's crazy. Wow, that's amazing. And when I went into audition, he was there and it was a little bit like meeting your pen pal that it's like, oh my God, wow, I can't believe, there you are, I can touch you. The person who's been catfishing. I didn't want to touch him, but yeah.
哦哇，太疯狂了。哇，这太神奇了。当我走进试镜房间时他在现场，那种感觉有点像见到了你的笔友，就好像，“哦天哪，哇，简直难以置信，真的是你，我可以摸到你了。”就像遭遇了网恋诈骗的人。我倒是不想摸他来着，不过对。
It's been real, yeah. Now your character in Anchorman looks very similar to the character in Friendship. Was that on purpose? No, it wasn't on purpose, although in Friendship, in the script, the character that I was playing was originally called Brian, which was the name of my character in Anchorman.
真是活久见啊。话说你在《王牌播音员》里的角色和《友谊》（Friendship）里的角色长得非常像。这是故意安排的吗？不，这不是故意安排的，尽管在《友谊》的剧本里，我演的那个角色原本叫布赖恩（Brian），这正是我在《王牌播音员》里角色的名字。
Wow. Wow. And I thought, maybe we should change that name just because I also have another mustache. The mustache was just something that seemed like, oh, this is the kind of thing that this guy would probably do. Yeah, yeah, for sure. It was a weatherman, he's a weatherman.
哇。哇。然后我想，也许我们应该把名字改一下，因为我正好还留着另一撇小胡子。留胡子只是因为觉得，哦，这大概是这货会干的事。对，对，肯定的。是个气象员，他演的是个气象员。
And so it's really funny, you're so good in it, and the movie is so great. Well, I gotta say, Tim, it's really Tim. And Tim is so funny. And I don't know if you've ever watched I Think You Should Be, which I think you probably have. He's a brilliant, brilliant, brilliant. He's incredible.
所以这真的太逗了，你在里面演得太棒了，而且这部电影也超级精彩。好吧，我得说，蒂姆，真正厉害的是蒂姆。蒂姆实在太搞笑了。我不知道你们有没有看过去看他演的《I Think You Should Leave》，你们肯定看过吧。他绝对是个天才、天才、天才。他太不可思议了。
I mean, he really has his own take on all of this stuff. And that was just such a blast to kind of get to work with him and see what he was doing. Have you ever seen his show, what is it, Detroit? Is it just called Detroiters? Yeah. What's his name, Tim what?
我的意思是，他在所有这些事情上真的有自己独到的视角。能有机会跟他合作，看他到底是怎么演的，简直太爽了。你们看过他的那个剧吗，叫什么来着，底特律？是不是就叫《底特律人》（Detroiters）？对。他叫什么名字，蒂姆什么？
Detroiters is incredible. It's incredible. Yeah, I love him, Jason. I remember I met him when he was a writer on SNL and everyone even at that time in SNL said, oh, I mean, this guy, Tim Robinson's the funniest. Yeah, he's the most unique. And he directed and wrote and is an actor
《底特律人》太绝了。绝了。对，我超喜欢他，杰森。我记得我第一次见他时，他还是《周六夜现场》（SNL）的一名编剧，当时即使在《周六夜现场》，每个人也都说：“哦，我的天，这家伙蒂姆·罗宾逊（Tim Robinson）是最好笑的。”对，他是独一无二的。而且他又当导演、又当编剧，还是演员，
in this film, Friendship? He is starring in it. He didn't write it. It might be the only thing I think he's ever done that he didn't write. However, the guy who directed it is a guy named Andrew D. Young. Yeah, he's great.
在这部电影《友谊》里吗？他是主演。他没当编剧。这可能是他做过的唯一一部他自己没参与编剧的作品。不过，执导这部电影的导演是个叫安德鲁·D·扬（Andrew D. Young）的家伙。对，他很棒。
He also wrote it, and he's friends with Tim, and completely captures Tim's voice. I mean, when I read it, I would've sworn that Tim wrote it. Was there a lot of improv on the movie? I mean, there was some, but you know, it's funny, when we kind of started, we were talking about it, and Tim said, let's take out all of the jokes. He wanted no jokes.
剧本也是他写的，他和蒂姆是好朋友，完美捕捉到了蒂姆的风格。我的意思是，我当时读剧本的时候，简直会发誓这就是蒂姆写的。电影里有很多即兴发挥吗？我的意思是，确实有一些，不过你知道，有趣的是，当我们刚开始的时候，我们正在讨论，蒂姆就说：“把所有的笑话都删掉吧。”他不想有任何笑话。
And so it wasn't really perceived as this silly comedy. I mean, I know that Andy, the director, said that he envisioned The Master, the Paul Thomas Anderson movie. We could do a weird comedy version, but very strange of that. And so it wasn't really, there was certainly some improvisation,
所以它并不是被当成那种无厘头的喜剧来构思的。我知道安迪（导演）说过，他构思时的愿景是保罗·托马斯·纳尔逊（Paul Thomas Anderson）的电影《大师》（The Master）。我们可以拍一个怪诞的喜剧版本，但要非常诡异的那种。所以其实并不是说，虽然里面确实有一些即兴发挥，
but neither one of us was trying to really hit anything too funny. And I apologize, can we see this now? It's coming out, can't see it now, I think it's coming out in, I don't know, April or May. Where the fuck did Sean see it? I got a little screen. He gets a link.
但我们俩都不是在刻意抖什么好笑的包袱。抱歉，我们现在能看到这部电影吗？马上要上映了，现在还看不到，我觉得大概在四月或五月上映吧。肖恩这混蛋到底在哪儿看过的？我拿到了一个小试映链接。
So depending on when this airs, you got connections, Sean. Yeah, so April, May, it's a spring release on this, huh? Yeah, yeah. Spring release. Like all the beautiful things that come out in spring. Well, we're really excited about it, we're really excited about it. We're really excited about you, Paul.
所以根据这期节目的播出时间来看，肖恩你路子挺广啊。对，所以四月、五月，这片子是春季档上映的，对吧？对，对。春季档。就像所有美妙的事物一样都在春天上映。好吧，我们对这部电影真的超级期待，非常期待。我们也很期待你，保罗。
We love you. You're a tremendous talent. I'm so happy. I'm really excited and bullish about your career. I think you're going to do great. Thank you. I'm so happy to be doing this. And like, it's such a, you guys are so awesome.
我们爱你。你是个了不起的天才。我太高兴了。我对你的演艺生涯感到非常兴奋且信心十足。我觉得你一定会大有作为。谢谢。我太高兴能来参加了。而且，你们俩太棒了。
Show is so funny. I'm so happy to be on this finally. I know. It's a crime. We broke a lean down and we got you here. Yeah, no, no, no. Look, you guys have, you got a lot of people to talk to. I'm honored to be one of them. Wow, we're very, very happy that you came.
节目太好笑了。我真的很高兴终于能上这个节目了。我知道。没能早点把你请来简直是个罪过。我们费了好大劲才把你请到这儿来。对，不，不，不。听着，你们俩，你们有那么多人要采访。我很荣幸能成为其中之一。哇，你能来我们真的、真的非常高兴。
Honored that you came. Thank you for spending some Saturday. I sure wish my connection was better. No, no, no, don't think twice about that. I'm not gonna say anything. At Honey Ham's or your wifi connection, none of it. Don't think. I'm not gonna, yeah.
你能来我们深感荣幸。谢谢你陪我们度过周六时光。我真希望我的网络连接能更好一点。不，不，不，别把这放在心上。我什么都不会说的。不管是关于蜜汁火腿店还是你的wifi连接，什么都不说。别多想。我不会，对。
We didn't talk about the Royals, we didn't talk about the Chiefs, we didn't talk about the Blues. Yeah, nobody wants to talk about that. Nobody wants to talk about that. By the way, well done with the Dodgers. You really wanna lose the audience? Shut up, baby, you don't even know what Tim Robinson has.
我们没聊皇家队，没聊酋长队，也没聊布鲁斯队。对，没人想聊这个。没人想聊这个。顺便说一句，道奇队的事干得漂亮。你真想把观众都气走吗？闭嘴吧，宝贝，你甚至都不知道蒂姆·罗宾逊有什么。
You get two U's, you get two episodes. I tell you who would turn the volume up. Jason Sudeikis and Claire McCaskill, that's who. Yeah, yeah, yeah, they would. What's Bobby Witt gonna do this year? And the great Dan Dees, also of Kansas City fame. The great Dan Dees friend of the show. The great Dan Dees.
你拿到两个U（指SmartLess双U标志），你就能录两期节目。我跟你说谁会把音量调大。杰森·苏戴奇斯和克莱尔·麦卡斯基（Claire McCaskill），就是他们。对，对，对，他们绝对会。鲍比·维特（Bobby Witt）今年表现会怎么样？还有伟大的丹·迪斯（Dan Dees），同样是堪萨斯城大名人。伟大的丹·迪斯，节目的老朋友。伟大的丹·迪斯。
Good friend of ours. Double D. Paul Rudd. Paulie. You're just. Good to see you, my friends. All the love to you and Julie and the kids. You're world-class.
我们的好朋友。双D。保罗·路德。保利。你简直。很高兴见到你，我的朋友们。向你、朱莉还有孩子们致以全部的爱。你太顶尖了。
Tip-top. Thank you. Tip-top, Paul. You guys are the best. And I can't wait to see you in person. It can't come here soon enough. Yeah, we'll be doing it. We'll be doing Candy Shop soon.
棒极了。谢谢。棒极了，保罗。你们俩是最棒的。我等不及要跟你们线下见面了。这一天快点来吧。对，我们会去办的。我们很快就会搞糖果店（Candy Shop）的活动了。
Yeah, we're gonna do a smartless outing. Let's do a live show from the candy shop. Oh, there we go. Look, any time you want. Claude Hoppers for all of you. That's a good fake name. I know something. We're sweet on you, Paul. Oh, there it is.
对，我们要去办一次SmartLess的实体活动。咱们在糖果店办一场现场秀吧。哦，这就对了。听着，随时奉陪。给你们所有人准备克劳德跳跳糖（Claude Hoppers）。这假名字起得不错。我知道点内幕。我们对你情有独钟，保罗。哦，这就对了。
Alright. Beautiful button! What a button! A candy button. I'm on my way to, I can only believe it. Pauly, have a great day, we love you, goodbye. Love you guys, thanks so much. Yes, goodbye. Take care.
好嘞。完美的收尾！多棒的收尾！一颗糖果按钮。我要去，我简直不敢相信。保利，祝你有美好的一天，我们爱你，再见。爱你们，非常感谢。没错，再见。保重。
Bye, pal. Paul Rudd, Paul Rudd, what can you say? I mean, we've said this before about people, but that is an overdue of overdues. Yeah, I know. Should have been on for a long time ago. It's almost embarrassing how overdue we are. I feel bad I didn't get into his stuff, you know,
再见，老兄。保罗·路德，保罗·路德，你还能说什么呢？我的意思是，我们以前对其他人也说过这话，但这绝对是拖得不能再拖、欠了天大情面的嘉宾。对，我知道。早就该来上节目了。我们拖了这么久才请到他，简直有点尴尬了。我甚至有点内疚没聊聊他的作品，你知道的，
like all the. You didn't get into anything, Sean. This is one of the least prepared episodes I've ever seen you host. And I can't believe a former member, Jason, a former Host of the year nominee, remember? Yo, for sure. Well, you know, but if he gets into the sugar,
比如所有那些。你什么作品都没聊，肖恩。这是我见你主持过的准备最不充分的一期节目之一。我简直不敢相信曾经的某位成员，杰森，曾经的年度最佳主持人提名者，还记得吗？哦，当然。好吧，你知道的，但如果他沾上了糖，
like any fucking little three-year-old, you can't count on him. Guys, I've failed you again. I bet they are regretting that nomination a couple years ago in that gang when they tried to get. Well, aren't you on that board too? Yeah, the iHeartRadio? Yeah. No.
就像任何他妈的三岁小孩一样，根本指望不上他。伙计们，我又让你们失望了。我敢打赌他们几年前在那个圈子里提名他的时候现在肠子都悔青了。话说你不是也在那个董事会上吗？对，iHeartRadio的？对。才没有。
These days I'm only bored when you're hosting, you know what I mean? No. Yeah. No. These days I'm only bored when you're hosting. You know what I mean? Yeah. Oh. I do think if we ever soften on the repeat guest policy, you guys are enforcing like fucking. Live show, he'd be a live show.
这些日子我只有在你主持的时候才会觉得无聊，你知道我的意思吗？才没有。对。才没有。这些日子我只有在你主持的时候才会觉得无聊。你知道我的意思吗？对。哦。我确实觉得如果我们偶尔对“拒绝重复嘉宾”的政策稍作松动的话，你们这帮家伙简直就像……现场秀，他绝对适合做现场秀。
Oh yeah, be a good live show. We'll be a good live show. We could just go through all its credits and talk about funny stories. Yeah, we'll go funny stories. I love that. Yeah, I do like that man a lot. But Willie, remember when he was talking about walking in Canada and he was walking on the,
哦对，会是一场精彩的现场秀。我们会办一场精彩的现场秀。我们可以直接过一遍他的所有履历，聊聊那些搞笑的故事。对，我们会聊搞笑故事的。我太喜欢了。对，我是真的很喜欢那家伙。不过，威利，还记得他之前说在加拿大散步时，他走在那个，
what was it? Here comes a bye. He was walking on the... He went to the... Bye-way! Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
那是什么来着？来电话了。他走在……小路上！聪明。透镜。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant-Terry. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant-Terry100%有机且手工匠心打造。SmartLess。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。